[Music]
what's up guys
michael here to talk about a bunch of
[Music]
that's right rugrats one of
nickelodeon's most beloved 90 shows
and sure the antics of tommy and the
gang are endearing but when it comes to
overthinking a kid's show
one thing really stood out to us their
parents that's because if we do the
very complicated arithmetic these 90s
parents are the embodiment of the
internet's favorite
object of ridicule boomers what's more
they're boomers raising millennial
children
even if the little tikes weren't called
that yet and once you start to think
about the show from that perspective a
certain
shift in meaning occurs because what if
we can understand a generation of people
obsessed with anxiety
memes and what harry potter house they
belong to through the story of their
parents
let us explain in this wisecrack edition
on rugrats and the rise of boomer
parents
and now for the briefest of recaps
rugrats as you know
spotlights a play group of babies and
toddlers the core original group
consists of tommy the idealistic leader
chucky the perpetual worrywort phil and
lill the worm love and sweeties and
angelica the bratty bully when their
parents leave the room their
imaginations go
wild leading them on many fanciful
occasionally horrifying adventures
for context rugrats debuted in 1991
and while the 80s and 90s are often
remembered as a time of relative
prosperity it
also was a time of widening economic
inequality and a rapidly shrinking
middle class
as a result many baby boomers entered
full-on adulthood
parenthood and estates of very real
economic anxiety they were faced with
demanding mortgage payments stagnating
wages and an unraveling social safety
net which to be fair
all still are things today these
anxieties manifest in the pickles
particularly in the early seasons dee
constantly worries about
money saying things like i've been going
over our bills stew and i thought maybe
if you got a job
outside the house she even grocery
shopped with a calculator to avoid an
unexpectedly high tab
and don't forget the calculator pop and
we're on a budget remember
here dede reflects the reality of being
a boomer during this era a reality
described by journalist anne helen
peterson's book
can't even how millennials became the
burnout generation peterson looks at the
plight of the stressed out millennials
starting with the trajectory of their
boomer parents
born between 1946 and 1964 baby boomers
entered the world during the relative
prosperity of the post-war economic boom
america had a robust social safety net
and middle-class workers could generally
rely on the support of labor unions
for those greatest generation parents
even a blue-collar union job promised to
middle-class
glory along with the ability to buy a
house and provide for your family
including your crying boomer baby as
scholar lewis hyman put it capitalism
worked for nearly everyone
but over the course of the next several
decades the rise of what political
scientist jacob hacker calls the
personal responsibility crusade
remolded american culture into one where
increasingly people were left on their
own to succeed or fail without the help
of gi bills generous social security
checks or a good union job
as a result boomers became grown-ups in
increasingly uncertain economic times
when maintaining a middle-class
lifestyle was becoming harder and harder
and for some people that worked out
really really well
especially if you had no moral qualms
about selling junk stocks on wall street
greed is right greed works
and for everyone else it was a huge
bummer one that rugrats may have
accidentally documented in cartoon form
for example
tommy's dad stew faces the constant
pressure of operating a small business
in a ruthless economy
still honey i'm worried about you i
think you've been working too hard
lately
the pressure stew faces manifests
physically he'll sleepwalk or be caught
talking to himself in a state of
over-exhaustion in one episode tommy
fancifully wonders if his dad
is secretly a robot and stu's
stress-induced sleepwalking confirms his
fears
here we see tommy accurately perceiving
the way economic anxiety weighs on his
father
at another point chucky similarly relays
his father's own concerns
i've always heard my daddy say he's
afraid the boss is gonna fire
him so what happened as baby boomers
adjusted to a new more
cutthroat normal as peterson describes
it the generation of weed token hippie
protesters evolved from being more
socially minded agitators to becoming
increasingly insular or as economists
matthias dupka and fabrizio zillabadi
put it they decided to look
out for themselves they invested more in
their education and individual success
while deeming social protection less
important
anyone who's seen rugrats could perceive
this cutthroat mentality in the
character of angelica's mom
charlotte the incessantly cell phone
chatting businesswoman and ceo of the
very ominous sounding
mega corp charlotte's known for saying
things like the junk bond market is
coming back and i for one
intend to be in a position to take
advantage of it her selfishness while
played for laughs
actually just exaggerates a very real
social and cultural shift that took
place in the hearts and minds of many
non-cartoon boomers
long before you were telling them old
ladies suck
now as boomers became increasingly
focused on the self and keeping that
self economically socially and
physically successful they were
vying to maintain middle class status
this new mentality resulted in the rise
of the yuppie that is the special brand
of college-educated boomer who according
to peterson can basically be defined by
their lavish consumption habits their
gadgets or vacations or french sparkling
wine
also quaaludes according to peterson the
yuppie mentality took form over the
course of the 70s metastasized in the
80s and became the base temperature of
the 90s
and make no mistake the rugrats parents
may be some of the yuppiest yummies ever
to yuppie as the la times noted in a
1998 review of the show
particularly in early seasons the
parents are hyper concerned with
projecting prosperity
the toughest show for one year old why
the little spreads aren't even gonna
remember it
they'll remember this one pop rated
number one by birthday's magazine and
besides do we want to be remembered as
the family that settled for less
they are super consumption happy lusting
after boats and fancy golf clubs
they film their banal vacations on their
camcorders there's dede packing for our
vacation to the grand canyon
oh it's gonna be a long night and obsess
over health food
don't order them any junk food or i'll
take your teeth away
they take their hobbies seriously and
present their new neighbors with
decorative jell-o molds and throw
nightmare-inducing costume parties
galore occasionally they even rent
limo buses to show off for their friends
we've even rented a limo bus to
celebrate stu's big night
of course there are moments of reprieve
from their yuppiness
the dueling realities of the boomer
identity between flower child and
sharper image loving yuppie comes to a
head in the second season when the
pickles throw a garage sale to reduce
bloated clutter of commodities like you
got your fondue set your crazy clava
lamb from that old stand by the pet rock
the children trying to be helpful move
all the beloved belongings that the
parents chose
not to sell outside and the family ends
up accidentally pawning off everything
they own
after a brief moment of panic upon
seeing their empty house
the pickles go full circle almost as if
retreating to the anti-consumption
ideals of the 60s
at least temporarily i mean all we lost
were material possessions
and what we've rediscovered are the
important things like
family and love and other real human
values hell they even sing
but for the most part they stay in
character
but what else did boomer yuppies do
according to peterson surrounded by
perceived threats and growing
uncertainty
middle-class boomers doubled down on
what they could try to control
their children and indeed nothing made
boomers more crazy than the pressure to
be good parents and provide well for
their spawn
early on the show sets this tone pretty
clearly as dd panics overthrowing the
perfect first birthday party for tommy
complete with a puppet show that no
one-year-old deserves
betty my future as a mother depends on
this party and the party depends on the
puppet show contrast her approach with
tommy's greatest generation grandpa who
was raised and became apparent in a more
hands-off age
why when i was a sput we didn't have
puppet shows
if we wanted entertainment we went out
back and pulled up stops
after the puppet show fails dede frets
that but i never live up to being the
kind of mother i want to be
you know like those moms on tv here dede
reflects the nearly omnipresent desire
among boomers to be a model parent and
to perform that good parenthood for the
whole neighborhood
she like many a millennial parent who
would come after her internalized a
stress-inducing message that as
sociologist sharon hayes put it the
methods of appropriate child rearing are
construed as child-centered
expert guided emotionally absorbing
labor-intensive and financially
expensive
this pressure is encapsulated by
deedee's realization a few seasons later
that she had abandoned her work on
dill's baby book
forever losing the chance to memorialize
the first time he burped or
pooped his pants better haul out the
baby book and write that down
again she feels like she's failed at the
same time boomers worried about their
child-raising methods they became
fixated on what sociologist annette loro
calls concerted cultivation
that is the process of carefully
developing their children via cello
lessons expensive summer camps and
ensuring that they're trilingual by the
age of 10.
but given the persistent economic
anxiety that permeated the era
these choices start to make more sense
it was all in the pursuit of their
desire to raise children who would
maintain their middle class status
if they failed they feared their kids
would grow up to be the lowly garbage
collector who keeps our neighborhoods
clean
rather than getting paid hundreds of
thousands of dollars to do whatever the
[ __ ] a consultant does
as peterson puts it the child's
well-being and more importantly their
future capacity for success
is paramount dede can barely get through
a sentence without referring to her
favorite child expert
lipschitz knows best too she obsesses
over the minutia of how she rears tommy
diapers wipees books blankets a cap a
change of clothes band-aids in case of
emergency and two extra bottles of chews
and takes him to maximum security
daycare the parents panic over bottle
feeding
this boy his parents didn't think it was
important to wean him
this child well you get my point
they panic over running noses i've tried
everything decongestants herbal remedies
chanting and boy do they panic over
potty training with chucky's dad
even fretting that he's gonna be taking
diapers to work with him in his
briefcase
here chas is literally worrying about
how his failure to potty train chucky
in a timely manner could be a threat to
the mini ginger's career and therefore
middle-class status
the boomer need to carefully cultivate
their child is best exemplified in an
episode when angelica takes up painting
for a very yuppy reason
my personal shaman said it was
absolutely the best way to nurture her
creative side
immediately her mother praises her work
saying i
love it what the total abandonment of
form the
disregard of balance it's so
jackson pollock little does she know
that this um
abstract expressionism is actually the
result of the babies fooling around with
paint that's a nice touch which
maintains the rugrats maxim that the
best things happen when kids are just
allowed to be kids
it's worth noting that concerted
cultivation also makes a prominent
appearance in a rugrats all-grown up
episode when the kids panic over a fifth
grade standardized
my entire future test on this test
meanwhile angelica's mom urges her to
start worrying about her college resume
giving her 11 year old daughter totally
normal advice
like you must do things that'll impress
the college admissions office
show concern for the environment your
fellow man
the grand result of concerted
cultivation was as peterson puts it
that boomers raised many adults
millennials who quickly grew up and
began
mimicking the habits of adulthood to
excessive anxiety
fittingly the rugrats are many adults in
a lot of ways
worried about living up to expectations
wanna go play in the sad box
i can't chucky oh my daddy went away
and wants me to be the man of the house
and worried like their parents about
their own child development
when she got to be a big baby anyway
also fittingly they're prone to
suffering from
real bouts of anxiety sometimes sounding
like they have the weight of the world
on their shoulders
life is so hard tommy angelica for one
becomes an
expert at performing her parents
expectations of a perfect childhood
what difference does that make who did
what the important thing is
that we're all here and we love each
other after
all family is really what matters right
of course she simultaneously develops a
low-key diabolical alter ego that allows
her to vent her pent-up
anger and frustration in the playpen at
the same time she seems to innately have
picked up her mother's love of luxurious
consumption
a hankering best displayed when she
harasses a mall santa until he quits his
job
so were the rugrats always doomed to
grow into the anxious depressed
burned-out millennials that peterson
analyzes in her book maybe
but we wonder if their fate was really
set in stone and for one main reason
the same reason that makes rugrats so
fun to watch unlike a lot of boomers the
rugrats folks are way too self-absorbed
to be true helicopter parents
that is to say their patented parenting
move is to put the kids in the playpen
and f the hell off this was perhaps out
of narrative necessity a show about
babies sitting on their parents laps
listening to classical music while
learning to read at age two and a half
is a lot less fun than a show about kids
wreaking havoc while imagining
themselves in outer space
as a result the rugrats get plenty of
time to themselves
away from their parents neurosis and
paranoias time to play
time to dream and that's something a lot
of middle-class millennial kids didn't
get much of
peterson notes that working-class
millennial children whose working
parents didn't have the luxury of
videotaping their every burp
often had a lot more free reign that
meant more of what she calls
natural growth or the conscious or
unconscious allotment of unstructured
time which allows children to cultivate
curiosity independence and learn to
negotiate pure dynamics on their own
inadvertently perhaps and despite their
very real anxiety and neurosis about
raising their children right
the rugrats parents give them a lot of
this unstructured time to do the
important things
like imagine themselves as pirates this
kind of play according to peterson
helps kids develop independence and a
strong sense of self
it also makes for damn good television
at the end of the day
rugrats is fascinating for its depiction
of boomer parenting while also
strategically leaving out one
all-important tactic of boomer parents
as peterson puts it
constant surveillance and protected
childhood we think that may be part of
the broad appeal of the show
at a time when kids increasingly had
less license to goof around
watching tv kids go on adventures
reminiscent of a different era was
extraordinarily appealing perhaps there
was some catharsis we might not have
been allowed to play outside
unsupervised but we got to watch the
rugrats build their own noah's ark in
complete freedom
but what do you guys think are the
rugrats parents exemplary boomer parents
would these lumpy babies have grown up
to be depressed millennials
memeing their way through our current
hellscape let us know in the comments
a huge thanks to our current patrons for
supporting the channel and a hello to
our new ones check us out at patreon.com
wisecrack for ad free videos and more
and before you go
don't forget to pat that subscribe
button real soft like it's the head of
your over protected five-year-old self
and as always thanks for watching later
[Music]
you